bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles et
cette semaine nous irons en espagne à
marina del à cette petite ville
andalouse défilé politique d'austérité
de madrid son maire à collectiviser les
moyens de production mais l'actualité de
cette semaine c'est bien sûr le prix
nobel de la paix accordé à l'union
européenne c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'europe mais ne s'agit-il pas d'une
erreur c'est la question posée par nora
hamadi
de nourrice nobel comme états
unis
l'europe prix nobel de la paix qui l'eût
cru
personne à vrai dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'europe pour ces
peuples c'est plutôt le prix nobel de
l'austérité dans les capitales
européennes les manifestations se
suivent et se ressemblent plan
d'austérité contre plan de rigueur
triple à contre pics pays du nord contre
état du club med cigale contre fourni au
pérou
d'une somme supra shoes
d'afficheurs riches est fort de good old
games and day for good on doit acheter
la mission au
pays des mots clés human rights in the
rest of the world mais tout le monde est
content c'est le principal à l'heure où
l'union s'englue dans la crise et
peinent à s'extraire de son inertie
portique cette distinction fleurs dont
la boutade ne faudrait-il pas mieux valu
couronner les pères fondateurs
alors ces prix nobel une erreur
alors nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
sylvie goulard bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne vous êtes française vous
appartenait au groupe des démocrates et
des libéraux ici au parlement européen
ce prix nobel de la paix parce que c'est
une erreur je comprends qu'on soit
surpris par le à part le choix en ce
moment mais je pense que c'est aussi une
invitation à réfléchir dans le temps et
dans l'espace dans le temps parce que je
pense que les jurés du nobel ont voulu
honorer toute la construction
communautaire ses soixante années de
paix la période la plus longue qu'on
n'ait jamais connu sur ce continent donc
je crois qu'il faut surtout éviter de
prendre les hommages pour nous c'est
plutôt des hommages pour ceux qui ont
commencé à un moment où c'était
difficile et oudin 6 avait suivi les
sondages à l'époque probablement on
n'aurait pas fait la réconciliation
franco-allemande et la paix et puis
c'est aussi un hommage dans l'espace ça
vient d'eux d'un penny qui est extérieur
à l'union européenne je crois que quand
on regarde l'état du monde même les
tensions qui existent en asie en ce
moment pour des conflits territoriaux
je pense que les européens peuvent
réfléchir un petit peu à ce que l'europe
leur a apporté après c'est pas une
raison pour nier qu'il ya des problèmes
graves est-ce que ça via pas malgré tout
un peu à contretemps moi j'ai été assez
surpris des réactions négatives des
citoyens européens qui disait
effectivement le prix nobel de
l'austérité on viens de l'entendre
l'europe a peut-être le prix nobel de la
paix mais là pas le prix nobel de
l'économie du social est ce que
finalement il aurait pas fallu que ça
vienne plus tôt
peut-être que d'ici peu moins qu'il ait
donné ce qui me frappe quand même c'est
que en ce moment il ya un espèce de
contresens qui est en train d'être
propagées
surtout que les ondes et dans tous les
tous les blogs etc c'est que ça serait
l'europe qui est la cause des problèmes
économiques elle a sa part de
responsabilité mais il faut bien appeler
aux téléspectateurs que les politiques
économiques étaient du ressort des états
membres et que justement on n'a pas fait
les politiques économiques de la zone
euro ensemble et donc il faut aussi
qu'ils s'en prennent à ceux qui les ont
dirigés dans chacun des pays et l'une
des difficultés qu'on a en ce moment
c'est de préserver un cadre que chacun
était censé préserver pour ce qui le
concerne et que certains ont
complètement bousillé donc encore une
fois il s'agit pas du tout de disculper
l'europe pour ce qu'elle aurait fait de
faux mais faire aussi remarquer que les
budgets en déficit l'absence
d'investissements dans l'avenir les
systèmes éducatifs en des capilotade
s'est pas non plus toujours la faute à
bruxelles alors on a appris
ce nobel est du distance de ce nobel de
la paix il ya quelques jours maintenant
est-ce qu ici au parlement européen il
ya une fierté par rapport à
l'attribution de ce prix savez moi je
trouve c'est toujours important de
savoir se réjouir y compris dans les
moments de difficulté encore une fois je
dis bien il s'agit pas de de fer
taratata et d'ignorer les difficultés
des personnes en europe et de beaucoup
de gens qui ont de qui affrontent des
conditions de vie difficiles mais je
pense à michel et les américains disent
tout le temps by positive soyez positif
c'est un des leitmotiv des américains
cirque eux toujours aussi de voir que le
côté négatif on peut de temps en temps
se dire tiens pourquoi est-ce que des
étrangers à l'union européenne considère
que ce projet vaut la peine est ce que
nous le jugeons bien ça fait réfléchir
là une autre information de la semaine
on a appris la démission d'un
commissaire européen du commissaire john
dalli qui était le commissaire à la
santé et aux consommateurs sur des
soupçons
de fraude est ce que en tout cas de
trafic d'influencé est-ce que la
corruption est quelque chose qui est
selon vous à ce présent au niveau
européen
d'abord je trouve que lorsqu'il ya un
problème que quelqu'un démissionne c'est
le signe que le système fonctionne
plutôt bien encore une fois je n'ai pas
personnellement des éléments sur ce qu'a
fait ou n'a pas fait monsieur dany je
trouve qu'il faut toujours être très
très très prudent avant d'accuser il ya
un service qui s'appelle l'office de
lutte antifraude qui semble avoir fait
un rapport effectivement qui aboutit à
des conclusions qui appelle des mesures
et je les approuve si elles sont exactes
il ya de la corruption mais si vous
regardez pas ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans un pays comme l'italie si
vous vous souvenez de ce qui s'est passé
au royaume uni au parlement je pense que
les êtres humains sont toujours soumis à
des tentations et que ce qui est
important c'est que les systèmes
politiques arrêtent les dérives sans
avoir l'illusion de penser qui en aura
pas il y en a au niveau européen sans
doute j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on
accable parfois l'europe sans regarder
ce qui se passe ailleurs au niveau local
ou au niveau national vous diriez que
simple un peu la même chose là c'est
plutôt il faut plutôt aller voir ce qui
se passe dans les états que ce qui se
passe au niveau de bruxelles il faut
assumer les responsabilités pour ce qui
a pu y avoir de négatif il faut jamais
le cacher mais il faut pas non plus
isolés ces questions-là de ce qui se
passe dans certains états membres où
vous avez des problèmes extrêmement
grave
dans les rentrées fiscales dans le
muselage de l'argent public par des
collectivités locales ou voir d'éclat de
corruption avérés dans des parlements
encore une fois je crois que ce sont des
phénomènes qu'il faut combattre parce
que la corruption c'est une un cancer
pour la société ça veut dire que
l'argent public est mal utilisé que les
décisions sont mal prises mais encore
une fois pour l'instant c'est un
commissaires sur 27 il faut qu'on attend
de voir les résultats de l' enquête
alors sylvie goulard il ya quelques
jours ici même au parlement européen
vous avez fait j'ai envie de dire
beaucoup parlé debout on va regarder une
petite intervention que vous avez fait
publiquement et ensuite on est nouveau
ensemble regarder
mario draghi
je m'adresse à mario draghi pas le
président mais l'homme de bon sens
comment voyez-vous les sept prochaines
années c'est en tant que président d'une
institution qui pousse tout le monde en
europe à se moderniser à mettre en
oeuvre des réformes structurelles pour
pousser plus de femmes au travail et qui
reste une institution du passé qui
n'emploie que des hommes mm il n'a ni
discrimination et non il n'y a pas de
discrimination à la bce mais bien sûr
toutes les institutions peuvent
s'améliorer en 12 matchs mort
bon alors pour que le téléspectateur
comprennent bien en fait vous parliez de
la parité ou de l'absence de parité
homme femme à la banque centrale
européenne il ya vingt-trois personnes
qui dirigent cette cette banque et ce
sont 23 hommes est ce que vous avez été
satisfait par la réponse du président de
la bce non j'ai pas été satisfaites par
sa réponse puisqu'il a dit qu'il ya pas
discrimination moi je trouve quand même
que quand on a des règles de droit qui
disent que a priori les hommes et les
femmes sont égaux et qu'à la fin on se
retrouve avec 23 sur 23 c'est quand même
un problème quelque part cela dit je ne
voulais pas accabler mario draghi ce
sont les ministres des finances qui sont
en train de prendre une décision à mon
sens non seulement grave mais un peu
bête pour être franche qu'il faut pour
dire les choses comme elles sont qui est
de désigner un sixième homme au sein du
directoire ce que les 23 c'est six
membres du directoire plus les 17
gouverneurs des banques centrales
nationales les 17 gouverneurs des
banques centrales nationales on peut se
demander pourquoi ya pas une femme mais
ça relève des états mais dans l'organe
qui est vraiment supranationale européen
on pourrait quand même au moins faire un
effort et quand vous parlez de parité
moi j'ai envie de dire on ne fait même
pas la charité parce que même pas un sur
six c'est lamentable est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est un combat qui est perdu
d'avancé puisque ici par exemple le
président du parlement européen martin
schulz a laissé entendre que cet effet
que ce sera ce luxembourgeois qui va
être nommé au directoire et c'est un
homme écouté d'abord moi je n'avais rien
contre ce monsieur mais je crois que
c'est une bataille qui valait la peine
d'être mené d'abord j'espère qu'on va la
gagner a priori on en a fait l'audition
n'a accepté de faire l'audition la
semaine prochaine parce que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre des groupes politiques se
sont mis d'accord pour rendre un vote
négatif
donc le conseil devra voter contre
l'avis du choisir ce monsieur contre
l'avis du parlement et puis moi je crois
que vis-à-vis des électeurs qui nous ont
envoyés ici vis-à-vis des femmes mais
aussi de nombreux hommes qui me
contactent qu'ils nous soutiennent dans
ce combat c'est un combat juste et ça
montre écouté que le président du
parlement le président du conseil
européen
tous les ministres de l'économie ne vois
pas le problème moi j'ai le sentiment
que la modernité est avec nous et c'est
eux qui sont aveugles et ringard mais
c'est à eux deux
j'aimerais comprendre le parlement va
voter contre alors que le président du
parlement dit que ça va être accepté
mais le président du parlement à son
interprétation de ce que nous avons fait
en commission économique et monétaire il
a probablement envie ça peut se
concevoir d'ailleurs de favoriser des
compromis il savait l'europe et beaucoup
fondée sur des compromis il ya des tas
de cas dans lesquels moi je soutiens le
comprend bien simplement là il n'y a pas
de compromis possible à la fin où on
aura un homme il n'y a pas d'autres
nominations pendant sept ans c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit à mario draghi est ce
que vous voyez pendant sept ans à la
tête de cette bande de mecs ou est-ce
que de cette banque de cette bande de
mecs parce que s'il faut bien appeler
les choses par leur nom tout le monde
est poli
tout le monde me dit que la parité c'est
un sujet d'une importance considérable
et ne fait rien moi je préférerais que
je parlement prenne ses responsabilités
votre nom et le conseil décidera un
compromis entre un homme et une femme je
sais pas quoi ça ressemblerait alors on
va maintenant faire comme chaque semaine
notre zapping des télévisions
européennes on s'arrête sur ce que les
médias étrangers ont décidé de traiter
et cette semaine c'était beaucoup sur
les indépendantisme en europe regardez
c'est un zapping signé aurélie la face
c'est décidé l'ecosse aura son
référendum avant la fin 2014 les
écossais ont donc deux ans pour décider
de leur sort dans la plupart des
sondages environ un tiers des votants se
prononce pour l'indépendance ce qui
laisse donc une large part de la
population indécise mais déjà l'idée
relance les velléités indépendantistes
catalanes le parlement régional souhaite
une consultation populaire
dans les rues de barcelone un espoir est
en train de renaître l'exemple écossais
a démontré qu'un accord était possible
le gouvernement catalan menace d'
internationaliser le conflit si madrid
refuse le dialogue la population
catalane continuent d'être divisée en
deux la majorité des catalans et pour
l'indépendance et veut que le sujet soit
soumis au vote et mâcha liées à la shoah
en belgique ce sont les flamands qui
envoie un signal fort le leader
indépendantiste bart de wever triomphe
inverse des élections locales à l'impact
national
et aux flamands a donné un signal très
clair pas seulement à la mer mais aussi
à la rue de la loi qui ne supportent pas
un gouvernement qui n'est pas supportée
par une majorité en flandre qui ne fait
que imposer les gens c'est inacceptable
cela doit arrêter la première étape de
la conquête de la flandre qui aura des
conséquences sur l'ensemble du pays ce
ce que j'espère oui
alors entre la flandre l'ecosse et la
catalogne est ce qui a selon vous des
points communs oui je crois qu'on
assiste à des phénomènes qui montre sans
amalgamer sont de l'ordre du repli
sur l'échelon régional parce qu'on s'y
sent plus à l'aise avec parfois aussi un
élément et c'est ça qui est très
inquiétant de refus de la solidarité
c'est la raison pour laquelle
personnellement je peux comprendre ces
attitudes mais je ne crois pas qu'il
faille encourager ces phénomènes la
dislocation des états européens
indépendamment de la construction
européenne à mon avis n'est pas une
bonne chose pour l'europe pour sa force
dans le monde et n'est surtout pas une
bonne chose pour le partage du fardeau
il ya des régions plus riches que
d'autres c'est vrai qu'elle paye parfois
plus que d'autres mais il faut aussi se
poser la question de savoir ce qu'est
une solidarité si les riches ne payent
pas je mets les pieds dans le plat qu'on
vous dit au début je suis assez
stupéfait aussi par le silence
assourdissant justement au niveau
européen face à ce que ces régionalisme
est également ccc nationalisme quand on
voit pas ce qui se passe avec aube dorée
en grèce à bruxelles personne ne dénonce
ça comment c'est possible non c'est
dénoncer je me souviens d'un débat
récent au parlement européen où on a
beaucoup interpellé monsieur barroso là
dessus en fin de sa vie mais lui non
mais lui même l'a dit dans ses discours
et d'autres je crois que monsieur van
rend payant n'est préoccupé la vraie
question c'est que ce sont des
mouvements profonds qu'un certain nombre
de partis politiques modérés qui
autrefois ne jouez pas avec ces idées là
jouent avec le feu que nous avons des
phénomènes de repli que nous allons des
discours identitaire nous en avons eu en
france récemment à des moments où nos
sociétés sont de plus en plus mêlés et
où la compétition mondiale est de plus
en plus redoutable je crois qu'il faut
inviter les gens à faire la part des
instincts des instincts et de la raison
c'est pas dans notre intérêt on parlait
du nobel de la paix
au début de cette interview parce que
malgré tout vous pensez pas que la
parole européenne devrait être plus
forte la dessus oui résolument oui il
faut combattre le nationalisme le
nationalisme françois mitterrand disait
le nationalisme c'est la guerre on croit
toujours que le premier stade est
innocent on croit toujours qu'on peut
flatter les identités et monter les gens
contre les autres et après il ya une
deuxième étape qu'on ne soupçonnait même
pas quand on s'est lancé dans la
première qui est celle de la dégradation
et peut-être même du conflit donc je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous nous
n'avons pas à avoir honte de ce qui a
été fait ici ça a permis peut-être
d'ailleurs que certains de ceux qui
critiquent aujourd'hui serait mort s'il
y avait eu des conflits et ils n'ont
même pas la décence de dire merci
schumann merci monnaie merci en tout cas
sylvie goulard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va continuer bien sûr à
parler de l'europe avec kathia gilder et
son invité nous allons partir en espagne
nous allons parler de la crise espagnole
et nous allons aller dans une petite
ville d'andalousie dans lequel le maire
a développé un modèle économique et
social unique là bas il n'y a pas de
chômage regardez c'est un reportage
signé sandra cerqueira
tout l'été ils ont marché sur les routes
d'andalousie pour dire non à la crise
derrière celui que les espagnols
surnomme robin des bois il a pris la
tête d'un mouvement de résistance
populaire bien décidé à convaincre les
maires de ne pas obéir à la politique
d'austérité
les coupes budgétaires se font sur le
dos des travailleurs
ce gouvernement de droite a fait tout le
contraire de ce qu'il a promis
c'est pourquoi il est légitime il faut
le chasser au plus vite
une marche et des opérations coup de
poing dans les supermarchés pour aider
les pauvres touchés par la crise
politique a on a bien sûr beaucoup
critiqué pour tout ça mais ça n'est pas
du vol c'est un acte d'insoumission sans
violence pour attirer l'attention et
montrer qu'il faut voir de l'autre côté
de la crise ceux qui n'ont plus rien
même plus de quoi manger
il faut une rébellion citoyenne pour
mettre en place un autre modèle
économique et politique
sinon ça va être terrible
c'est le militant de la gauche
anticapitaliste qui parle il y à 30 ans
juan manuel gordillo décide de lancer
dans sa ville une expérience des plus
originales petite commune andalouse
située à une heure de séville
des noms de rues évocateur et des
fresques au slogan de révolte
pas de police municipale
une sorte d'enclavé communiste en plein
coeur de l'europe fondée sur une
économie à 90% public alors que
l'andalousie et la région espagnole la
plus touchée par le chômage avec un taux
de 34 % à marinaleda tout le monde
travaille
une bonne partie des habitants est
employé par la coopérative de la ville
créée par les ouvriers agricoles eux
mêmes après des années de lutte
en 1992 ils obtiennent gain de cause et
exproprient 1200 hectares de terre
la terre doit être à ceux qui la
travaillent dans le pays ça va mal et
nous on a la chance de ne pas connaître
le chômage notre exemple montre qu'on
est une solution viable face aux marchés
quel que soit leur poste à
responsabilité ou nous tous reçoivent la
même chose 47 euros par jour effectue
une rotation afin d'assurer un revenu à
tous
l'objectif de la coopérative ce n'est
pas de s'enrichir c'est de donner du
travail et ça on ne le voit pratiquement
nulle part
les autres ils veulent gagner toujours
plus d'argent
mécanisée pour qu'il y ait le moins de
main d'oeuvre est ici ce n'est pas ça le
but
mais avec la crise ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à venir postuler pour
travailler dans les champs
difficile de donner du travail à tout le
monde parmi les chômeurs qui arrivent
beaucoup était dans le bâtiment au
moment où l'espagne et on croit au boom
de l'immobilier marinaleda décide
d'aller à contre-courant en favorisant
l'autoconstruction il est possible d'y
louer une maison de 90 m² pour 15 euros
par mois
il faut absolument que chacun aide à la
construction de son logement et à celui
de ses voisins
on est 18 dans la rue on s'entraide et
si on ne peut pas le faire on fait appel
à quelqu'un d'autre de la famille
c'est la commune qui propose les
terrains et fournit le matériel
nécessaire à la construction des
logements
on est subventionnée on rembourse en
payant un peu chaque mois
sera propriétaire que dans 60 ou 70 ans
c'est une façon d'éviter la vente et
donc la spéculation
de même il est impossible de nous côté
quai car on ne fait pas appel aux
banques pour un crédit
lusine de la coopérative où les récoltes
sont mise en conserve appartient aussi à
ceux qui travaillent les moyens sont
collectiviser et les prises de décisions
aussi les habitants participent à des
assemblées publiques et décident
ensemble de ce à quoi est destiné le
budget de la ville
de cette façon on est sûr que les
décisions sont bonnes pour tout le monde
ça n'a pas l'air comme ça mais on doit
lutter parfois durement pour imposer ce
système municipal
beaucoup de politiques pourrait suivre
notre exemple mais ça ne les intéresse
pas que tous ne puissent vivre dignement
menace procès à droite comme à gauche on
critique un système qui sans les aides
publiques de la communauté autonome
d'andalousie ne serait pas viable
d'autres dénoncent le populisme d'un
homme réélu régulièrement depuis 30 ans
qui chaque samedi et en direct pendant
une heure sur la télé locale de la ville
située juste à côté de la mairie
voilà pour ce reportage réalisé par
sandra cerqueira à marinaleda et pour en
parler nous accueillons monsieur miguel
angel martinez bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen espagnol socialiste et
démocrate on vient de voir ensemble à
quoi pouvait ressembler un îlot rouge si
je puis dire au coeur de l'europe est ce
que pour vous c'est totalement utopique
ou au contraire est-ce que ça peut être
une solution de la crise non seulement
non seulement ce n'est pas utopique mais
mais c'est
celui ci a rien de nouveau là-dedans
savez il ya ya soixante dix ans en
espagne
il y en a eu le communisme libertaire et
le
le passé la tradition anarchiste qui
fait qu'en espagne il ya eu
dans le dans ce qu'on a appelé l'anarcho
syndicalisme
c'est des expériences qui ont eu lieu un
peu partout
elle c'est une expérience qui était
peut-être plus
plus imaginable dans le contexte
agricole fondamentalement agricole du du
début du xxème siècle en espagne je
pense que à l'heure actuelle c'est une
c'est une moi je pense que c'est une
c'est un cas qui qui qui est
nécessairement touchant parce que c'est
une réaction qui n'est pas seulement la
réaction d'un homme de dieu qui est
quand même la réaction d'une d'une
commune qui n'est pas un village qui a
tenu tête au niveau européen on dirait
quand même une petite ville
c'est sympa c'est pas du tout le travail
et habitant le trait est à peu près
trente mille habitants de cette ville
donc c'est une ville avec tous les
problèmes la ligue je pense que c'est
une c'est une initiative
touchant de jouer à la limite et c'est
une initiative qui se situe
absolument en dehors de tout contexte
l'équipe qui qui pourrait-il pourrait
d'ailleurs amené à une très grande eau
sur station un moment mais est ce qu'on
peut imaginer d'appliquer ce genre
d'expérience à une échelle plus large on
peut tout on peut tout imaginer mais
comme l'imagination parfois elle fait
défaut et on peut tout imaginer mais
ceux que j'oublie remonteront montre la
copine ça il ya des milliers et des
milliers de coopératives en espagne qui
fonctionne d'ailleurs où les gens où les
gens vont travailler dans ma province
n'est pas très loin de l'andalousie je
viens de la mancha ty avec des
structures sociologique
c'est similaire avec partie de la
culture de l'histoire espagnole de façon
d'un mariage dans ma région emilie des
centaines de coopératives où les gens
sont en train de travailler des gens
trouvent du travail où l'on trouve du
travail pendant des périodes pendant des
périodes relativement limité donc c'est
moi je pense que c'est une c'est une
initiative touchante cette initiative
intéressante certainement et je ne crois
pas que l'on puisse imaginer
un phénomène en cascade qu'il fallait
que tout le pays et que toute l'europe
deviendrait un mécanisme de ça fait ça
me fait penser moi omar tsé toung
absolument dépassées par la réalité
chinoise au jour il ya eu beaucoup de
portraits sur robin des bois espagnols
comme on en n'avait pu l'appeler comment
est il perçu en espagne est ce qu'il est
perçu comme un sauveur ou au contraire
contre comme un dangereux utopiste non
non non non non non mais franchement je
pense qu'il est je pense qu'il il y à il
y a quand même chez le personnage aussi
ne le cachons pas il ya des gens qui ont
parlé et il a
vraiment ça me
sais que c'est quand même c'est
quelqu'un aussi qui vit beaucoup du
médiatique
comprenez vous la vente pure consiste à
une émission à la télévision locale
chaque jour ou presque j'ai lu ça donc
il ya un autre populisme non mais je
vous dise mais c'est de toute façon dans
le local ça se passe dans base au clos
c'est pas ça ce qui est important pour
lui c'est qu'on en a parlé à parler un
peu partout à l'espagne mais même à
l'extérieur je vois bien et que l'on a
parlé parce que ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
vraiment fait c'est défier la loi c'est
à dire se mettre orale c'est aussi ça
fait partie aussi la
2de de la confusion générale qui est en
train de s'installer en espagne alors
justement dit qu'elle angel martinez par
l'idée les candidats au travail à marine
et là il ya aussi beaucoup de d'anciens
ouvriers du bâtiment secteur qui est
vraiment le point noir en espagne est ce
que est ce qu'on a réglé ce problème
immobilier qui est quand même le talon
d'achille de votre pays qui goûtaient je
pense que notre
notre faute et dans une certaine mesure
notre chèque ça a été de savoir que ce
processus de bâtiments bâtiment bâtiment
était vouée à l'échec
ça veut dire c'était aussi de
l'immobilier spéculatifs c'est ça le
problème aujourd'hui l'espagne jouera
aujourd'hui d'abord aujourd'hui
je ne veux pas dire hélas mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de
bâtiment qui pousse ni spéculatif non
spéculatifs ayant le problème
aujourd'hui il ya des centaines de
milliers de logements vides alors que
personne ne veut acheter ou ne peut
acheter et donc cela il ya des il ya des
dizaines de milliers de logements qui
ont été vendus à des gens qui dans des
conditions alors que les banques que
savait qu'il n'allait pas pouvoir payer
ou que normalement à un moment où
l'autre y briller et on est en train de
de leur enlever ces bâtiments ces
logements pour payer et une fois qu'ils
ont payé à y payer moins que ce que
soi-disant la banque
justement puisqu'on parle des banques
est ce que la situation de est-ce que la
situation de l'espagne notamment de ses
banques inquiète l'europe et on parle
d'un éventuel nouveau plan pour aider
les banques est-ce que ça c'est
compréhensible alors même qu' à 25% de
la jeunesse ce panel aux chômage parce
que ça vous choque qu'on aide les
banques
moi je je je pense que
l'aide aux banques devraient être
beaucoup plus conditionnée qu'elle ne
l'est fallait il qu'elle devrait être
absolument conditionnée à un certain
contrôle est jeune
je ne comprends pas comment on peut
aider des banques qui continuent à payer
des sommes très importantes et j'avoue
que je dois je crois en vous mêmes ma
naïveté parce que je n'avais jamais pu
penser
croire aux sommes qu'on est en train
d'apprendre maintenant que toucher des
membres de conseils d'administration
mais c'est là qu'ils n'administrer rien
et pitié et fiction qui ont amené des
des sociétés à la ruine et qu'ils ont
continué à toucher donc donc inutile
qu'il fasse qu'il fasse soutenir les
banques je veux bien qu'il a conditionné
ce soutien de façon extrêmement sévère
je pense qu'il est indispensable aussi
et que le fait que l'on puisse soutenir
les banques sans un contrôle sévère est
connue la population amène l'indignation
de nombreux citoyens comme c'est le cas
actuellement merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'invitée d'europe hebdo on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine à strasbourg avec
nora hamadi travaux type de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires